[Music]
hi good afternoon I'm Yandy I'm with
Shopify I'm a director on the data
platform engineering team and earlier
this year we started migrating our data
center from on-prem in Chicago up to
Google Cloud Shopify is a leading
cloud-based commerce platform we started
in 2012 we have about 600,000 users
active merchants in spread around 175
countries and together they've sold
sixty three billion dollars worth of
merchandise so that's really Shopify by
the numbers but what Shopify tries to do
is also make a place where an individual
brand can there we go can and an
individual merchants can build its brand
and build their brand and really find
out the voice that they their unique
voice and be able to bring that to
market and we would try to support them
through our customer support our
ecosystem of apps and developers and
really just try to make sure that
they've got every advantage that they
can so this is why we're here
my senior VP of data in the fall of 2016
said all data processing needs to be in
the cloud by q4 fortunately he didn't
say what year but it still kind of had
us thinking and worrying and so that's
what he said implicitly he also said we
can't have any SLO violations our
customers still need to be able to get
their data insights and the business
Shopify needs to be able to answer the
questions it has and also no data
disruptions so we couldn't lose data we
couldn't corrupt it during this
migration so we managed to do it and I'm
really excited to tell you about it but
first I want to talk a little bit about
the data platform as it was in the DC
sort of how it grew up so this is gonna
be really brief introduction to our
infrastructure so this is how it started
these servers arrive the same week I did
and my bootstrapping onboarding task was
to bootstrap these nodes it took me two
days to realize that our HDFS nodes
didn't have any hard drives in them once
we figured out why we couldn't install
an OS everything kind of went smoothly
so from there once we had the machines
up and running we installed HDFS as our
data Lake for file storage yarn for
compute and running all of our jobs the
jobs primarily our SPARC and that's
where all of our ETL does happens
modeling the data and then finally about
two years ago we introduced presto as a
query engine so that we could make all
of HDFS data available and queryable via
sequel to our analysts and the rest of
Shopify so final state we had 11
petabytes of storage by the time we
migrated we were using about nine and a
half of it hour between presto and yarn
we had of around 250 compute nodes we
added 80 terabytes of data per day this
is net new the amount that we actually
produced was a lot higher around 250
terabytes but that was with our
lifecycle management really net new was
just 80 terabytes and then finally we
run 25,000 ETL jobs per day on that nine
petabytes of data so from pretty humble
beginnings we grew to a pretty big size
and we were starting to feel the strain
of managing this infrastructure with a
small team we went from buying servers
to buying racks to building out data
cages
so what does it do basically this just
lots and lots of ETL this is where
people do their exploration their
modeling where we build data insights
both for our internal customers but also
for merchants so it breaks down sort of
the way we think of it logically into
data acquisition which is how the data
comes in this is data pulled in from our
my sequel shards and also our Kafka
message bus plus third-party services
like github or Zen hub then once the
data lands data processing takes over
these are this is the majority of the
SPARC jobs that then take this data
model it and build out sort of the data
artifacts and data assets that we use to
power our business but also help our
merchants and then finally we've got
data discovery and access and this is
really how the data assets make it back
to our customers and it's mainly through
tableau or mode for exploration and
reporting and then we've got redshift as
an analytic database and then also
presto for querying an exploration so
that was the start of that's where we
were January 2018 and then we found out
our data center and contracts were up
and in July so we had six months so we
had roughly five infrastructure
engineers 15 to 20 data engineers and
six months so for us it we really had to
focus on time to cloud and we sort of
made a bunch of decisions around that to
make sure that we could get out of the
data center as quickly as possible so we
were optimizing for speed and trying to
also not impact our customers like the
data scientists and really try to
replace what we had and make sure
there's as much of an implementation
detail as possible so to do that what we
did was we moved to we really just
wanted to lift and shift our
sure we understood HDFS yarn and spark
and this is also what all of our
customers were familiar with we didn't
want to burden them with having to port
all of their models and all of their
jobs over if we could just move it up to
GCP without them seeing or having to
worry about it but as much as we didn't
want to use new services we also wanted
to be pragmatic and use services where
it made sense so for us there was an
operational burden running things like
HDFS so if we could shift that
operational burden over to Google we did
it and then we also knew that we needed
to get out of the DC quickly and into
GCP and we knew it wasn't going to be
perfect but we didn't just needed to do
the job and be able to get all of our
data assets rolling again so we looked
at we knew that there was lots of
optimizations we could do once we had
the flexibility of being in Google cloud
so we wanted to but none of those
optimizations would actually help us get
out of the DC faster so things we could
do with compute preemptable VMs running
clusters that are specific to the
workload those sorts of things are great
but again they wouldn't help us move out
of the DC faster so the first piece to
move was data discovery this is kind of
like starting with dessert first but
there's a reason we did this so just as
a reminder data discovery this is really
the portal into the data warehouse that
we gave all of our customers within
Shopify so this is presto for querying
and also tableau and mode for reporting
so these are the reasons why we chose to
do the data discovery first one of the
big ones is that there was no data set
dependencies really all the consumers
wanted was the latest data we didn't
have to worry about operational
interdependencies to actually generate
this data also we knew we're gonna have
to move
that sort of three and a half petabytes
of data up to GCP so we're gonna have to
get good at moving data anyways so we
might as well do it with a slightly
lower load and then it was also the one
feeling the most pain we presto usage
took off like wildfire
we started with four nodes and had to
scale out to sixty within a year and it
ohso and it runs twenty five thousand
queries per day across the three and a
half petabytes of data that we have so
when presto really is our query engine
and sequel engine to all of the data in
HDFS and when we look at our data like
we think of how we think of it in two
ways we've got the raw data which is how
what data acquisition brings in this is
really just operationalized data that we
bring in consolidated and have a
historical record of and then there's
the model data assets which are cleaned
and built by our ETL framework so this
is what it looked like in the data
center basically we had HDFS and presto
redshift was our first analytic database
and it only contained front-room data it
don't
so once front-room data was built by the
ETL we'd package it up we ship it up to
s3 loaded into redshift and then people
could start reporting off of it presto
had access to all of the data in HDFS
and that's where it queried from so all
it needed to do is really a metadata we
just sort of say this is the latest data
you can start querying that this is the
pipeline that we had to build for the
migration so the good news is that we
already knew how to move quite a bit of
data because we already moved the data
from HDFS test3 for front-room data and
then we added this new pipeline to move
the front room data from HDFS up to
presto the one part that we didn't quite
have yet was for the raw data and this
is where the majority of that 250
terabytes that we build every day
goes so we had to work with our network
team to make sure that we didn't DDoS
ourselves going with all this data at
the front door so our network team
looked at looked at the amount of data
we wanted to move and also the latency
and this was sort of an important piece
too was that we had to go and understand
what our customers wanted in terms of
latency for them new data is generated
around every 48 hours so an extra 15 to
20 minutes of needing to wait for the
freshest data was ok they nothing would
no relevancy would be lost by this lower
latency so after discussing
understanding that the latency concerns
that we had what how much data we wanted
to move in also wanting a little bit of
headroom for growth we decided we got
for 40 gigabit direct connects with
Google and made sure that all data
coming from our data warehouse was
segregated and ran specifically over
those links so that we wouldn't impact
anything in the date of anything else in
the data center and moving this data we
had already gotten good at sort of being
as part of our workload uploading the
the front room assets and now we also
needed to upload the back room assets
and register them but this was just
another step in the workflow that we
already understood and knew well so for
part of our migration we docker eyes
presto one of the reasons we did this
was in the DC we maintained everything
with chef our configuration management
but that wasn't gonna be maintained once
a chef itself wasn't gonna actually be
supported once we left the DC so we
needed to move away from it and we also
wanted to have a mutable infrastructure
so this is the format that we came up
with we have presto docker eyes it's
pretty simple and easy one to docker
eyes and then we also docker eyes all of
our monitoring and logging tooling all
of these run as system d-unit file
sorry unit services and we ran on
container optimized OS we chose that
because we wanted
it gave us it's optimized for docker and
we also didn't have to worry about
somebody going on to in a bun to image
or something and running scripts and
installing stuff and slowly the clusters
started to drift we already had a very
good pipeline for version control and
building out docker containers so we
just kind of jumped on that so once we
had the nodes we started using Google
deployment manager to actually be able
to deploy to clusters and this gave us
the ability to quickly iterate because
we didn't have to slowly stand
everything up and make sure the config
files were there we could just lean on
Google deployment manager for that also
presto has it's pretty simple there's a
coordinator and workers to do the work
and this gave us an easy way to start
understanding how a deployment manager
works and how to actually build out more
complicated clusters and we used
instance groups so that we could scale
at the workers on demand so once we had
the cluster and everything up and we're
moving the data we started to run in
parallel with the DC we made sure that
we could stage at the day stage the data
that it was consolidated and it was
reconciled to make sure that the data we
thought was there is actually the data
that was there then we opened it up to
in a forbade Oh to some data scientists
were super eager to go and start using
it because they could get away from the
current cluster which was overloaded
with too much work so after we
reconciled made sure the data was there
and were comfortable with how we were
deploying it and felt it was ready for
production we flipped the switch so
until now the DC presto was still
running and it was the single source of
truth when we were ready we switched it
over so that we made we switched all the
reporting to start going against GCP
this was in late q1 that we switched
over so once we had the Presto up and
running we also wanted to
worried about think about security a bit
more so in the DC we secured it with VPN
at the edge but what we lost there was
some audit ability because without a
plugin presto just allows anybody to put
whatever username that they want into
the user field so we knew the people
that were using it so it was okay and
there was trust within the data org but
we wanted to open it up to more than
that and so what we did was we created
an OAuth proxy which is similar to the
identity aware proxy and basically what
happens is a user will log in via this
proxy in their web browser follow the
OAuth flow that they're used to we get
back a sign token from Google then the
then the user can connect to the client
and their proxy and that sorry that
client will proxy their request along
with the token up to the server once
it's on the server we now have this
signed JWT token that we know exactly
who it is and then we can set the
username before it goes into presto so
this gave us end-to-end auditability on
all of our queries so that was moving
presto now so we've kind of started with
the end of the meal and now we're gonna
actually so I guess set the table so
again this is how all of the data enters
our data warehouse we pull it in from my
sequel shards from Kafka and from and
from third-party sources I could have
it's really the only place where we've
got operational snapshots of the data
and this is the base of all of our ETLs
so speed boat is the tool that we built
to run our data our data acquisition
there's it's written up in this sort of
unholy pairing of JRuby and Scala it's a
basic change data capture and it
produces again full snapshots of the
operational models and the way
if I Korres is running in our DC as
we're sharded so that means we've scaled
all the shops horizontally and the data
warehouse is really the only place you
can get a consolidated view across all
of Shopify so speedboat has two main
phases one is the extract phase this is
where we actually pull in the new data
and this is basically like a select star
we're updated at is greater than
whatever so we get back all the data
that's changed since the last time we
did this and then we fold that into an
existing snapshot to produce the new
operational table at that time so for
this for moving to the cloud we had to
move to we started leveraging some
managed services and this part was
really good because it allowed another
team not just the infrastructure team to
actually be able to own their
infrastructure they decided to use
Google Cloud or sorry Google kubernetes
engine as the extractor and co-located
that with with Shopify core to be able
to access all the databases they also
used data proc to be able to build these
snapshots this was all built on top of
SPARC and Scala and then we used Google
Cloud Storage for our storage engine our
storage layer so this is how it looked
and basically speedboat would run its
extracts from all the different shards
it would land those extracts onto GCS
and then data proc would pick it up fold
the new changes into the existing
snapshot and put it back down on GCS and
that's how we got the root for all of
our modeling so this is the piece that
took the longest and this is the hairy
big hairy beast that nobody really
wanted to tackle this is the heart of
our data warehouse and this is where all
of the raw data gets refined and put and
built where we build out the data assets
it's insanely complex so
about a third of our dependency graph
that's 3,500 individual jobs which run
25,000 times a day so in the DC I've
mentioned this before
we have a young cluster running on top
of HDFS as our data Lake and PI spark is
the the main driver for all of our data
and et le so at Shopify we started using
spark and PI spark specifically around
the latter part of 2013 and into early
2014 and so we've got like a lot of
legacy baggage that came along with that
one of them was that we had to be able
to distribute our work across the
cluster we couldn't just run it in on a
single node and this was before yarn
cluster mode was fully available so what
we had to do was docker eyes our driver
make sure that everything was there all
the native libraries and then we could
actually run that dr. driver anywhere in
the cluster to spin up a new yarn job
and we weren't confined to a single box
and again because of PI spark there were
a lot of native libraries that we had to
deal with so numpy some pi syuh these
were all native libraries that we had to
compile and run and it took about 40
minutes to bootstrap a new node with
these dependencies alright so how did we
migrate this to the cloud so we again
looking at time to cloud we had to make
a couple choices upfront and the made
one of the major architectural changes
we made was going from GCS or sorry from
HDFS to GCS and this was again trying to
deal with context free versus context
full so something where we didn't have
any competitive advantage of running
HDFS ourselves
and also it's cost prohibitive and GCS
or in GCP to run HDFS so we decided to
move to Google Cloud Storage there was
also the added benefit that Google cloud
storages API is compatible with HDFS
file system API so it was kind of a
drop-in replacement but GCS isn't a file
system and this caused us a lot of grief
it it's sort of similar if you're
driving a car with an automatic
transmission and then you swap out and
put it and give it a manual transmission
you're still gonna be able to drive but
now there's a lot more things that you
have to worry about and for us there
were a lot of built-in assumptions with
the way that our framework r44 ETLs did
its job mainly about atomic directory
moves that doesn't happen anymore
so what we had to do was add Sentinel
files to ensure that we weren't picking
up partially processed data so again we
took the same approach we had chef
running in GC P or sorry and RDC and it
was it had grown organically that the
the configuration management for this
for Hadoop had grown organically I tried
for two months to refactor it but then
rage quit so we didn't want to bring
this ball of yarn and this mess up with
us to GCP so again we looked at docker
izing everything we this was a more
complicated deployment than presto but
we'd already sort of understood some of
the best practices from going through
the Presto migration so we again use gdm
for deploying and managing our
deployments and then we decided to use
standard Google compute engine VMs to
deploy onto so we desperately wanted to
use data proc but these 40 but we
couldn't ever get the boot up time for
data proc cluster to be under 30 minutes
and that's because of all these native
libraries that we had to compile
and build-up so there was no way of
actually amortized the cost we wanted to
pay that cost of building once and then
be able to deploy quickly so what we did
was we leaned on the fact that we had
already docker eyes and paid the cost
for those for the drivers for all of our
ETL jobs and then what all we needed to
do was really overlay the node manager
and resource manager libraries overtop
and so now we could go down from 40
minutes to spin up an new node down to 2
to 3 so this is what we ended up with
again
it's very similar to to the presto nodes
we had we have the node manager running
all the jobs all of our logging and
monitoring are also docker containers
built up on container optimized OS the
one thing that we had to change though
was the way that we launched ETL jobs
because of the docker container we had
to actually mount the docker socket into
the node manager so when it spun it up
it would use the VMS dr. Damon to
actually spawn these jobs we had some
issues to where now all of a sudden if a
node manager failed because they weren't
managed by the system D service they
would keep running headless and
potentially caused some data corruption
so we had to add add in some hooks into
the system D unit file to make sure that
if the node manager ever shut down we'd
go and reap all of the docker containers
so as our deployments became more
complex and we deployed to more projects
and we also had more services coming
online we invested in building something
we call data deployment manager which is
really just a wraparound gdm to sort of
enforce our best practices around how we
want a package and deploy it versions
our deployments and it also makes other
teams more autonomous because now
instead of having to make sure that they
configure
the gdm deploy exactly the way we want
to we can automate this process make
sure that they're running the latest
version and also have the latest version
of the configs so how we manage our
configs this is something that we built
in addition to the data deployment
manager and this is configurator it's a
system to manage and deploy application
across our clusters it works by keeping
versioned
configuration files and source control
and having a sidecar container run on
each of the VMS that start up the config
the the sidecar is the first one to
start up it will pull down all the
different config files and runtime
information that we can get from the
metadata API and using a templating
library we can stitch these all together
and put them into a amounted docker
volume which then all the other services
on that node can pull off of so they
don't actually need to know how to what
the latest config versions are or how to
stitch them together they just need to
know which ones they want pulled them
down and put them in the right place
before they start up so this allowed us
to also separate concerns of building
the docker containers and deploying the
configurations and the nice thing to
hear is that we can now roll out config
changes without having to bounce the
entire cluster to configure a configure
a tour we'll pull it down and build out
the latest version of of the configs and
then make sure that the services picked
them up so this is how we built out the
node and we built out the deployment and
made sure that we can do the
configuration properly so once we were
ready for the migrate so our migration
plan once we had that it was really just
get the infrastructure ready so the end
the end piece that you see here with
configurator and our data deployment
manager that was something that evolved
over the entire my
is still evolving what we did and what
we wanted to make sure of is because of
the type time deadlines that we weren't
bottlenecking
anybody above us from running tests or
anything like that so basically we lied
lied cheated and stole to get our first
cluster up to make sure that people
could start running some smoke tests and
then as we saw where the bottlenecks
were and issues were we kind of refined
our process and made sure that it was
repeatable faster and faster once we had
some infrastructure ready what we wanted
to do was fire some tracer bullets to
make sure that the end-to-end workflow
worked as expected that there weren't
any huge performance issues or
networking issues or security issues
that we just hadn't thought of this we
did this before we had to worry about
that huge dependency graph I showed
before and it was really just a one
end-to-end workflow with no dependencies
so once we were comfortable that we
understood how we could run one job from
end to end we needed to look at how to
stage the data and move it move all of
the data from the DC up to GC P and this
was so that we could start running
essentially a full production workload
once we were confident that at least all
the tooling was there to be able to run
it so once we had staged the data and
started to spin up her production
workload we ran in parallel with the DC
again and this was to make sure that we
could reconcile the data and this is
also a place where we made some
decisions so before the data acquisition
layer I was talking about how there's an
extract phase and that is actually
depending on when you do the extract you
might get different data and so this is
something where we now have the
potential to add a little bit of wobble
into the root of our tree which just
kind of gets echoed throughout the
entire process so we wouldn't have had
any hope of properly reconciling the
data if we introduced noise at the root
so what we did was we actually left the
extracts running in the DC even when we
were running in parallel and then we'd
push up those extracts to GCP and then
run the snapshot so this way we ensured
that at the root of all of our ETLs the
data matched exactly so we ran in
parallel in the DC made sure that we
could reconcile all the data nothing
changed again we didn't violate SLO as
or SL A's and then finally we flipped
the switch again so until this point
presto and redshift and all of our kin
all of our data that was consumed by our
customers was running from data that
came from our DC so we always wanted to
mange maintain and make sure that we had
a single source of truth we didn't want
to have some data in DC and some data in
the GCP and then have to synchronize so
basically from at one point we just
started to flip we flipped the switch
and started doing reporting from our
from our or sorry we started loading
data from GCP instead of the DC and
slowly moved to all of our data to have
the single source of truth in GCP before
we shut down the DC alright so that was
the bulk of our migration these again
these are the logical pieces that we
moved there was dozens of services
involved in them and so here's a brief
timeline so in q4 2016 David gave the
mandate that by q4 I'll I'll propel data
processing needed to be in GCP then 2017
was pretty much all entirely eaten up by
contract negotiations and working with
Google and this is a piece that I hadn't
factored into my estimates when I was
building out capacity and budgeting for
our data center needs
for the data warehouse I kind of assumed
that we'd have the contract signed and
we'd be able to get going and we
wouldn't need to scale as much so it was
a bit of a scramble and it was this game
of not wanting to invest in hardware
that we knew we were only gonna use for
a handful of months versus actually
making sure that we didn't violate SLO
so it got a little tight near the end so
we managed by April 26th we managed to
run all production out of GCP without
any SLO violations or data disruptions
and as of July 1st we shut down the data
center so one of the things that you
need to think about is really what are
you optimizing for is it cost or is it
time to migration for us it was time to
migration we knew that we were gonna
potentially be inefficient with cost our
executives knew that and they were okay
because maintaining two legacy systems
or sorry maintaining two operational
systems and also having to renegotiate
DC contracts if we slipped was going to
be much more expensive and harder to do
for any longer than we absolutely needed
to the other part is really using the
right tools so for us use lean on
managed services as much as possible if
you can shift operational burden away
from your team and onto Google that's a
win but you also need to understand the
trade-offs for us we wanted to shift the
operational burden of running our yarn
cluster to Google but we couldn't
because of these boot up times and we
knew that data prop was working on this
but at the point when we needed to make
the decision it wasn't ready yet and we
weren't ready to bit bet all of our ETLs
on a product that wasn't in alpha or a
feature sorry that was an Intel in alpha
yet so this is picking the appropriate
path forward you really have to just
even if you know it's suboptimal and it
might raise the operational burden
you pick the path forward that you need
to make sure that you can optimize
towards what what you're looking for and
then for the migration plan really for
us it was trying to iterate as quickly
as possible so we wanted to make sure
that we were never a bottleneck for
upstream consumers and that we could
fire these tracer bullets as quickly as
possible
and correct any issues that we saw so we
really wanted to make sure that we were
fast and then if something broke we
could mitigate it quickly and then try
and push the system and figure out any
edge cases as fast as possible and then
for us to it was identifying the logical
pieces that we wanted to move for us at
and that dependency graph it didn't make
sense to try to move the entire or move
one piece at a time the
interdependencies were too complicated
and would have slowed us down and so
what we ended up doing was again slicing
everything vertically and managing to
just move it in bulk over and and being
able to isolate it to a single team that
would work on moving their piece once
the infrastructure was in place so
that's it
thank you
[Music]